(ominous music)
- [Ruby] That's me, Ruby
Maguire, residential advisor.
(ominous music)
(creaking)
(whispering)
(jazz music)
Judging from the camera, candles,
and sexual paraphernalia,
(cracking)
I'm guessing we have a
rogue pornographer on campus
with a penchant for
Satanic bondage erotica.
(popping)
- Probably trying to cash
in on the big money world
of co-ed nudie films.
- Apparently they have a library card
and a taste for VHS.
- Dang!
There's no tap in the camera.
He covered his tracks well.
- He?
- The Slippery Squatter.
- Who?
- The Slippery Squatter, a con artist
masquerading as a student.
Living in the dorms, attending classes,
all tuition-free.
I've been on his trail for two years now,
and every time I think I'm getting close,
he slips through my fingers.
- How do you know it's the Squatter?
- Because the Squatter always leaves
seaweed snacks in the hideout.
- Oh my God, the Slipper Squatter
is a myth, officer McCoy!
Some students left some
sex toys in the basement
as part of a prank, or I'm
not Dean Jean McDoodlestein.
- [Ruby] Jean McDoodlestein,
dean of students
and former professor of gene research.
McDoodlestein and Roy were lovers once,
until their romance came
to an ignominious end.
- The Squatter is as real as you and me.
He's gotten cocky, and
now he's gotten reckless.
He's making adult films
right under our noses!
- Just give us two days
and we can nail this guy.
- No.
I am not perpetuating some crazy myth
that there's a student who's phony
and making sexy videos on campus.
Not during finals week.
- But we have to--
- No.
- Come clean, Jean.
This is about you and me.
- No, I'm over it.
(shouting)
- McDoodlestein is blind, Roy.
We can nail this guy together.
- I can't have you getting
involved in this, Ruby.
Not with McDoodlestein
breathing down my neck.
It's too risky.
- But I can help you.
- You're a college kid, Ruby!
It's finals week!
Focus on that!
Sharpen some Ticonderogas, huh?
Look at some ScanTrons, prepare yourself.
Leave the detective work to me.
- This is a 1993 VHS copy
of the romantic comedy,
Cannibal Potluck, starting Joshua Jackson
and Juliette Louis.
- Who was the last person to check it out?
- Bobby Sokolov.
- [Ruby] Bobby Sokolov,
a friendless germaphobe
at the bottom of the campus food chain.
Rumor has it he can only go
pee-pee in a plastic bottle.
(beeping)
- [Voice On Phone] This
is Bobby, leave a message.
- Bobby.
(knocking)
Bobby!
- Bobby?
- [Ruby] Art Carlisle, Bobby's teammate
on the Raretin University Mathletes.
- Former teammate.
I haven't seen Bobby since
he quit the Mathletes.
- Why'd he do that?
- Shacked up with some girl.
- Do you know her name?
- Something with a B.
- That's okay.
- I mean, we were on a
three season winning streak.
We were stacking checks,
we were cashing checks,
we were checking boxes.
I was checking out chicks.
It was the (censored) shit.
Wait, why are you looking for him?
- We have reason to believe
that Bobby's been involved
in the production of
unauthorized adult films.
We found this VHS he had checked out
of the library at the crime scene.
- Figures.
Ever since he got a girl,
he thinks he's hot shit.
Last time I saw him,
he called me a douche.
To my face.
Just because I'm a 17 year old whiz kid
who happens to be really
passionate about math
does not make me some kind
of a little bitch, okay?
(dinging)
Maybe I should hold onto that,
just in case Bobby shows up?
- This is actually evidence
in the ongoing investigation.
- All right, then you should bring it to
his Film Criticism teacher.
He'll know what to do with it.
- Can Charlie get you anything?
Water, coffee?
- [Ruby] Dr. Dumpling and
his TA, Charlie Fiddle.
- I'm good, thank you.
- Well, I am just
disappointed by all of this.
Bobby is one of my best students.
And pornography?
He loved our curriculum.
- What was that, exactly?
- Obscure 90s romantic comedies.
- That explains the VHS I
found at the crime scene.
- Ah, Cannibal Potluck, a tour de force.
- Yeah, Art said you were
gonna drop this off with us.
- That's actually evidence
in the ongoing investigation.
When was the last time you saw Bobby?
- Well, I haven't seen him
for a week because of finals,
but I think he's in a study
group with Belinda Bak.
- Belinda Bak, what year is she?
- I'm not sure, but she's
one of my brightest students.
- How do you spell that?
- No student by the name
of Belinda Bak here.
- Are you sure?
She's auditing a class, Dr. Dumpling's
History of Obscure 90s Cinema.
(clacking)
- Nope, no student by
the name of Belinda Bak
at Raritin University.
- The Slippery Squatter!
- Miss Maguire, I just had a conversation
with a member of the Film
Criticism Department,
and apparently you've decided
to continue with the investigation.
- Because I'm an RA, and I'll be damned
if I let someone shoot
dirty movies in my dorm.
- Well, perhaps a week of house arrest
(gasping)
will relieve you of your curiosity?
- Rats!
(tragic piano music)
- [Roy] I'm sorry about all this, Ruby.
- It's my own fault.
I just can't turn it off.
- Neither can I.
- That's why we make a good team.
- (censored)
I know the Squatter is real!
If we don't find them, I'm
gonna go cuckoo bananas!
- [Ruby] You can still find them.
- No, Bobby knows the
Squatter, you know Bobby.
You've got the best shot
at cracking this thing.
- What are you saying?
- I'm saying you overpowered me,
you stole my mace, you
sprayed me in the face,
and you tip-toed on out of here.
- No, Roy.
- Yes, Roy!
This is the way it's gotta be!
- But they'll have your badge for this.
- I traced the video camera
to a repair shop downtown,
Last Resort Video, a real dump.
You can pick up the trail there.
- Roy, wait!
- Good luck, Ruby!
(screaming)
Find the Squatter, Ruby!
Find him!
(epic music)
- How could you let her get away, McCoy?
You are finished here!
Finished.
- Again!
- Ah, man, I love these old things.
(sniffing)
- Seaweed.
- The handle can give you
really bad carpal tunnel,
but it'll last forever.
- Any idea who you sold this to?
- I can't remember, I
have to ask my colleague.
Belinda?
- Belinda Bak, the
Slippery Squatter herself.
Why couldn't you answer your damn phone?
- I'm so sorry, we were
cramming for finals.
Belinda's boss let us crash
up here when we studied.
Look, it wasn't us.
Belinda and I don't even
like those pornoooos.
- Give me one reason I
shouldn't haul you in
for trespassing right now.
- It costs $40,000 a
year to go to Raritin.
I can't afford that.
- Look, she audits some classes
and has to crash in the occasional dorm.
That doesn't make her a bad person.
- Then why was the movie you
check out from the library
at the crime scene?
(gasping)
- Cannibal Potluck?
I thought I lost this months ago.
- But what was a beautiful
90s movie like this
doing at a crime scene?
- Give me the VHS player.
(ominous music)
- Ugh, it's like an
abstract bondage porno.
(grunting)
(groaning)
- Ah-ha!
(grunting)
- Okay, okay, fine, fine, fine, fine.
There is somebody recording avant-garde
bondage pornography here on my campus.
- But they all got masks on,
so there's no way to tell who they are.
- Au contraire.
This video proves that the mastermind
behind the underground bondage porno ring
is in this very room.
- [All] Who?
- Tina Tinklejoy and Polly Nomial.
- Tinklejoy Productions.
- Recognize your letterhead, Charlie?
Tina Tinklejoy is Charlie
Fiddle's pseudonym,
or should I say, nom de porn.
- I can't believe it.
- What can you believe, Art?
Or should I call you Polly Nomial?
- That's just a coincidence.
- Is it a coincidence that
the vintage video camera
found at the crime scene
happens to cause carpal tunnel?
- What about the seaweed?
- Free with the purchase of a camera
at Last Resort Video.
They must've enjoyed a
salty precoital snack.
(crunching)
- [Art] So simple, so addicting.
- [Both] Fine, we did it!
- Why'd you do it?
- Because I needed the money.
You walked away from a fortunate
in Mathletes prizes, okay?
You left me in the dust.
I'm just an 18 year old student
trying to make his way through college.
Who's gonna pay for my tuition, huh?
- Get a flipping loan.
- And you.
I am so sick and tired
of 90s romantic comedies.
I wanted to make a thesis film
that would disgust your taste
as much as your taste disgusts me.
- I had no idea you felt this way.
- [Both] Why are you such a prude, Ruby?
- Hey, Ruby's no prude.
Probably.
But if you two wanna get your rocks off
shooting some low-fi erotica
in the privacy of your
own home, be my guest.
But as soon as you cut a lock
and break into an out of
bounds zone in my school,
you've broke some rules, bucko.
McDoodlestein.
- That's Dean McDoodlestein to you, Roy.
Art, suspended indefinitely.
And Fiddle, terminated,
effective immediately.
- What?
- Why are you surprised?
You recorded porn with a
student in my buildings.
- What about Roy?
- Roy, Roy, Roy.
(scraping)
Can you not do that, Roy?
Reinstated.
- Hah!
Haha, the Slippery Squatter.
I knew they were involved in this.
Who is it?
- I'm sorry, Roy, I can't.
I made a promise to someone.
- I maced myself for you.
I thought we understood
each other perfectly.
Guess I was wrong.
- Another who-done-it solved,
another wrongdoer laid bare,
another layer of skin peeled away
from this rotting corpse
we call a student body.
Till next time.